Le temps est l'une des choses
les plus précieuses qui soit.
Il est à la source de notre vie,
de notre âge et de nos souvenirs.
Il écrit l'Histoire, tue ce qui vit,
comme les plantes, les animaux, les humains,
mais aussi ce qui ne vit pas.
Il use et détruit les objets.
Le temps tue l'art.
Divers moyens de réparer les objets précieux
ont néanmoins été découverts.
Certains ont produit d'excellents résultats,
comme la restauration, en 2010, de
"La chambre de Van Gogh à Arles" avec des couleurs contrastées.
Et d'autres non,
à l'image de l'artiste amateur qui,
en Espagne, a détruit la peinture murale
"Ecce Homo", datant du XIXe siècle,
en utilisant des techniques de restauration maison.
Il existe un moyen de préserver les objets,
que je trouve particulièrement intéressant.
Il s'agit de la numérisation3D.
Imaginez que nous puissions
réparer la Vénus de Milo.
Que faisait-elle avec ses mains?
L'artiste Cosmo Wenman l'a représentée
avec une quenouille de fileuse à la main.
Cette technique permet de réparer des objets
et de les protéger d'une nouvelle manière.
Certains musées,
comme le British Museum, ont été numérisés.
Il est possible d'explorer virtuellement les allées
et galeries de ces musées à l'aide de StreetView.
Certains proposent même, sur leur site Web,
de télécharger des numérisations3D d'objets d'art.
Vous pouvez me croire, les numérisations3D
d'objets d'art sont de plus en plus courantes.
CyArk est une organisation à but non lucratif
qui vise à préserver les sites historiques.
Ses membres projettent des faisceaux lumineux
sur les surfaces de lieux tels que le Mont Rushmore,
l'opéra de Sydney
et même sur des abris utilisés
dans le cadre d'expéditions en Antarctique.
Les scanners3D mesurent des millions de points
par seconde pour une précision à quelques millimètres près.
CyArk recueille ainsi des informations structurelles complètes,
qui seront utiles à l'avenir pour la conservation
de l'ensemble des sites historiques.
La nécessité de protéger ces monuments
et objets découle de nombreux facteurs,
dont la détérioration causée par les rayonsUV,
la pollution industrielle et l'homme lui-même.
Il peut s'agir de la façade en marbre
du Taj Mahal, usée par les pluies acides,
ou des trois précieux
vases chinois du XVIIesiècle,
brisés par un visiteur ayant trébuché sur
son lacet au Fitzwilliam Museum de Cambridge.
Oups…
Les conflits ont toujours
été des ennemis de l'art.
De la bibliothèque d'Alexandrie
aux livres brûlés par les nazis,
les hommes ont détruit
l'œuvre de siècles entiers.
Pensez au Moyen-Orient.
Les membres du projet Rekrei, anciennement
"projet Mossoul", effectuent un travail formidable.
Ils utilisent le crowdsourcing ainsi que des
photos de bénévoles pour créer des modèles.
Ce projet fut lancé suite à la destruction
de sites historiques dans le nord de l'Irak,
aux pillages et à la vente d'objets d'art
sur le marché noir en Irak, en Syrie et ailleurs.
La protection de la culture est
en effet un outil politique important.
La numérisation joue souvent
en faveur des artistes réduits au silence.
Fin janvier dernier, l'artiste Banksy a réalisé
une peinture murale inspirée des "Misérables"
en face de l'ambassade de France à Londres
pour dénoncer le traitement des migrants à Calais.
Bien que l'œuvre
n'ait été exposée que quelques heures,
elle est conservée et reste accessible à tous
grâce à Google StreetView.
La numérisation3D et l'archivage
nous permettront de protéger l'art et le patrimoine
en les transformant en données.
Des données indestructibles et éternelles.
Si l'on peut télécharger ces modèles
afin de reproduire les œuvres,
il ne s'agit pas uniquement de réparer
et de protéger, mais aussi de partager.
Il n'y a alors plus de limite, et vous
pouvez reproduire un musée chez vous.
Si vous recherchez un buste de Zeus,
il vous suffit de l'imprimer depuis votre canapé.
Si nous imprimons tous
les mêmes objets d'art en plastique,
un matériau de moindre valeur,
est-ce toujours de l'art?
Qu'en est-il de la protection?
L'art est-il conçu pour
ressentir l'effet du temps?
Pour le subir?
Si nous réparions la Vénus de Milo,
voudriez-vous encore la voir?
Je suppose que non…
Il est de notre devoir
de protéger et de partager l'art.
Pour nous, nos enfants et nos petits-enfants.
Mais, paradoxalement, en le protégeant et
en le partageant, risquons-nous de le détruire?
Ne me regardez pas comme ça!
Je vous pose juste la question.
Répondez-moi en laissant un commentaire ci-dessous.
Prenez soin de vous jusqu'à notre prochaine discussion.
Consultez notre chaîne
pour en savoir plus sur l'art et la culture.
Vous pouvez regarder d'autres vidéos
et vous abonner pour ne rien rater.